welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and the Mandalorian season 3 just
went Jurassic by resurrecting the
mythical mythosar the massive creature
whose skull adorns Essentials the armor
the coverts of the surviving
mandalorians dot to be extinct for
thousands of years but alive and well
and wet in the Living Waters beneath the
minds of Mandalore the ending of chapter
18 leaves us with so many questions
about the history and the biology of the
planet of Mandalore and in the Star Wars
Universe which I started to dig into in
yesterday's breakdown but in this video
Let's just break down everything we know
about this planet and its Dino also
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive with even more pointed analyzes of
the titles you love and he can support
us by grabbing some merch at
nerdriot.shop like the vasmonod from our
deep dive collection okay so Mandalore
is a setting that we have visited quite
often in Star Wars Canon especially the
animated series of Clone Wars and Rebels
where we see the mandalorians living in
domed cities like sundari to protect
them from the scorched terrain of the
planet that scorching what's caused by
the Mandalorian cataclysm which came at
the end of the final war between the
mandalorians and the Jedi historically
these two groups of people have hated
each other and the armor actually
referred to these wars in season 1
chapter 8. the songs of eons pass tell
the battles between Mandalore the Great
and an order of sorcerers called Jedi
yet an order of sorcerers basically this
lady saying they're all witches now in
Star Wars Legends continuity there was a
figure named Mandalore the first who led
a group of fellow tongues from Coruscant
and settled on the planet roon before
moving on to a jungle planet that would
become known as Mandalore this would
have been sometime in 7000 BBY Mandalore
the first was the first person to use
the title of man Allure but again that's
Star Wars Legends it's not necessarily
considered Canon even though they are
bringing in elements of it back into
canon in recent years of canonical Star
Wars titles like Clone Wars Rebels the
Mandalorian the book of Boba Fett the
Ancient Ancient Ancient history of the
Mandalorian people has been applied to
be a lot earlier like Rebels established
the history of the darksaber as over a
thousand years ago in the days of the
Old Republic tar vizla a force sensitive
human became the first Mandalorian to
join the Jedi Order he forged the dark
saber after he died the darksaber was
kept in the Jedi Temple but members of
the Mandalorian house Vizsla broke into
the Jedi Temple and stole the darksaber
back where they would use is darksaber
to rule over Mandalore for many many
years the Old Republic then fell in 1032
BBY but Mandalore the great it sounds
predates all of that history this plaque
that bocaton reads by The Living Waters
and the minds Mandalore reads these
Minds date back to the age of the first
Mandalore according to ancient folklore
the minds were once a mythosar layer
Mandalore the great is said to obtained
the mythical Beast it is from these
Legends of the skull Signet was adopted
and became the symbol of our planet we
also know from the ugnot quill from the
Mandalorian chapter 1 that the ancient
mandalorians tamed and rode the mythosar
you are a Mandalorian your ancestors
rode the great mythosaur surely you can
ride this young Pole now sometimes these
sponsorships are me talking about hair
care but to even get to caring about
your hairy I gotta hang on to the hair
that you got and that's what keeps us
forward keeps offers clinically proven
research-backed treatments to stop hair
loss and improve hair growth two out of
three guys will experience hair loss by
the time they're 35 but with keeps you
can get quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or a pharmacy
all keeps treatment plans are
recommended by a licensed medical
provider and delivered straight to your
door at about half the cost of a
traditional Pharmacy each treatment plan
comes with a full year of unlimited
messaging so you can connect with your
medical provider about anything anytime
keep says a network of Expert Medical
advisors prescribers and Care
Specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality whether you're
looking to prevent hair loss stimulate
hair growth or just take better care of
the hair that you have keep says you
covered hair loss stops with keeps to
get a special offer go to keeps.com new
rockstars or just click the link in the
description that's keps.com new
rockstars yeah this line was in the very
first episode of the Mandalorian from
that moment they were calling their
shots of where this is all headed one of
these mandalorians is gonna ride this
thing now Mandalore is a planet has gone
through several waves of environmental
and ecological Devastation according to
Star Wars build the Millennium Falcon
magazine number 32 Guide to the Galaxy
the history of Mandalore the mythosars
were believed to have been extinct
Legends they were actually hunted into
extinction by Mandalore the first 7000
prior but either way they were
supposedly long gone by the time of the
Mandalorian cataclysm in which their war
against the Jedi caused this planet to
get scorched into sand like this but now
we know that Extinction did not happen
at least one layer of mythosars remained
active in the Living Waters though
presumably the mythosar's survival
remained a secret because bogoton didn't
know about it and it never came up among
the members of The Watch the watch as
the cult came up on the moon of
Concordia away from the surface of
Mandalore after house vislo was banned
there after losing the uprising to the
forces led by bogoton's father so
Mandalore continued to look like a
Barren planet with Dome cities
throughout the Clone Wars and throughout
most of the Galactic Civil War when we
saw it in Rebels it had not yet been
bombed but the Mandalorian in the book
of Boba Fett established that there was
another wave of Destruction called The
Purge or the night of a thousand tears
in which Imperial bombers led by MAF
Gideon nukes the planet in its cities
with Fusion bombs going through the
ashes stealing any best guard they could
find and leaving it as the Wasteland it
is now its Sands melted down into Green
Glass in its cities about abandoned and
covered in debris but as we now begin to
explore these ruins of Mandalore Diner
is surprised to discover that the
planet's air is breathable conditions
are not toxic and fauna has survived
alamites and reptilian bats suggesting a
food chain that could allow for an apex
predator and sure enough a city-sized
mythosar is living in those Living
Waters this mythosar is aquatic or
amphibious like Kaiju from other fiction
Godzilla a Titan that intohos mythology
was awakened or activated by human
nuclear testing in the Pacific now it
remains to be seen if this big boy will
be a force of Destruction or a gentle
giant I'm assuming the latter especially
since grogu with that Rancor has proven
his ability to tame large ferocious
beasts but these Living Waters according
to the plaque were known to be a
mythicard layer in ancient times making
this a kind of prehistoric fossil site
like the La Brea Tar Pits that's how
bogoton reads it this was just a sacred
sight to her people that she grew up
with she never really thought there was
anything magical or special about it so
for an actual living dinosaur to be just
beneath the surface of her old field
trip reflection it must be terrifying to
her since poketon grew up with these
Waters and millions of people living in
sundari never really had any reason to
believe it Kaiju was beneath their feet
I'm willing to guess that it was those
Fusion bombs of the night of the
Thousand tears that brought back the
mythosar not necessarily by radiating
them into giant sizes the way they do
Godzilla but perhaps just simply by
clearing all of industrialized life off
the planet for the first time in
thousands of years wiping out all that
noisy activity from the best car minds
and rebalancing the ecosystem and
allowing the mythosar to grow to its
full adult size like this so the Mythic
star were not hunted out of Extinction
they just receded to the waterways
beneath the planet's surface and they
went dormant and like the dragons of the
House Targaryen and The Song of Ice and
Fire mythology their disappearance from
the universe coincided with the fall of
a great house living on only in banners
Legends and other iconography but based
on its size now there is no way this
mythosaur could crawl out of the mines
up to the surface there must be another
back door a network of waterways it uses
to navigate like the Naboo waterways
occupied by the massive Sando Aqua
monster there's just no way this Mythos
are could grow this big without room to
swim and also there may be others from a
thematic standpoint the return of the
mythosar represents a critical
restoration of faith for bocaton and for
members of the watch but till now
they've been feuding over the darksaber
but really the darksaber replaced the
mythosar as a United symbol for the
Mandalorian people but the darksaber
never really did that relatively
speaking there was a more recent
historical artifact that has really in
practice only ever divided mandalorians
from each other it requires them to
fight each other the darksaber is their
curse but the mythosar a symbol far
older than the darksaber and a symbol
more purely Mandalorian with no sorcerer
stink on it is their redeemer hey a
reminder to subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive and support us by grabbing
something from the deep dive collection
at nerd riot.shop you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA boss follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]